Hola buenos días la Unión Europea lleva
meses intentando encontrar una base
legal como utilizar estos bienes
confiscados de oligarcas rusos y también
las reservas del Banco Central de Rusia
para ayudar en la reconstrucción de
Ucrania actualmente la Unión Europea
tiene unos 18.000 millones de euros
aproximadamente de activos de oligarcas
rusos Además más de 300 mil dólares del
Banco Central de Rusia que están ahora
mismo inmovilizados por parte de los
países de la Unión Europea pero también
otros países del g7 pues lo que quiero
hacer la comisión europea es que con la
base legal actual que existe Es que
siempre que uno oligarca ruso por
ejemplo intente violar las sanciones que
ahora mismo están aplicadas en la Unión
Europea Entonces se le pueda confiscar
este bienes porque la Unión Europea no
puede utilizar una confiscación de todos
los bienes congelados esto sería i Solo
sería se podría ser posible en caso de
que se violaran las sanciones el dinero
confiscado se podría utilizar por
ejemplo en la construcción de un fondo o
bien de un instrumento internacional que
servirá para la reconstrucción de
Ucrania aún así la comisión europea
insiste en que este instrumento con este
dinero confiscado siempre tendría que
ser temporal porque se legó la
legislación internacional una vez se
levantan las sanciones se tienen que
devolver estos bienes así pues lo que
quiere la comisión europea es que sea
este fondo Temporal y que esté ligado a
un futuro acuerdo de paz y también
siempre y cuando se cree un fondo de
reconstrucción a Ucrania en caso de que
se firme la paz entre Ucrania y Rusia la
propuesta legal la hará la comisión
europea este viernes Aunque hoy ya está
presentando el papel a las capitales
europeas bueno Esther también le quiero
preguntar cómo quiere Entonces esta
comisión europea llevar ante la justicia
Rusia por la invasión a Ucrania este
anuncio de wonderline también que pedía
desde hace ya varios días
Sí así es la verdad es que la creación
de un futuro tribunal es una de las
cosas más complicadas la comisión
europea admite que hay es un laberinto
legal incluso de hecho la Unión Europea
ha planteado un documento de discusión a
las capitales hoy mismo también en que
existen varias posibilidades de lo que
se podría hacer por ejemplo que la
fiscalía de la Corte Penal Internacional
intenta recabar el máximo de pruebas
posibles de hecho la fiscalía ya ha
estado en el terreno en Ucrania para
intentar documentar posibles crímenes de
guerra y también un posible genocidio
también se prevé que por ejemplo que se
pueda crear un tribunal y especial en la
haya para poder estudiar estos crímenes
tal y como se hizo por ejemplo la guerra
de los balcanes con la antigua guerra en
la yugoslavia y por otra parte también
se puede estudiar que por ejemplo Las
investigaciones que están llevando a
cabo varios estados miembros se pueda
crear lo que conocen se conoce como un
tribunal híbrido en que se pueda crear
un tribunal en uno de los países
miembros pero con ma internacionales
esto podría ayudar en la en el análisis
y también en la en la comprobación de
que se ha habido crímenes de guerra en
cualquier caso la Unión Europea insiste
en que esto no se puede hacer sin el
aval de Naciones Unidas Así que es muy
complicado